ich bin
nein
echten
du bist mein weg mein ziel so gar nicht
gerne
einen wunderschönen guten morgen du
schöne ist ich denke so doris machst du
denn hier
du hast doch heute frei ich schob
restaurants überraschung für mich nicht
ich muss auf meine linie aber eine
überraschung habe ich auch für dich du
fährst morgen zu dem termin in bonn
du musst brückmann media unser konzept
präsentieren was saba präsentation hast
du doch bisher immer gemacht er habe bis
jetzt schon aber mir ist was
dazwischengekommen
oder muss sich fragen wer denn
guten morgen lukas leder mal kannst dich
nicht ewig davor drücken herauszufinden
schule ist
außerdem wollte er mehr zweite
geschäftsführer von solar maschinen
wurde verhaftet wegen unterschlagung
wer hat was unterschlagen das weiß wohl
nicht natürlich ein gefundenes fressen
für die presse
ich muss schadensbegrenzung betreiben du
musst nach bonn fahren aber willst du
drückt man media ist die nummer zu groß
für mich also bei so einem wichtigen
kunden solltest du dabei sein
du bist mein partner du schaffst das
schon entschuldige mich bitte ich muss
jetzt mit dem pressesprecher von
solaredge ins telefonieren soll ich
bleiben und die hilfen auf gar keinen
fall
ich krieg das schon alleine hin
ich kann morgen beim besten weniger weg
ich habe die unterlagen zu gemeldet man
dann zu geht um 8.39 uhr früh weißt du
was heute für einen tag ist klar
mittwoch kein riese seinen fahrern im
land parieren
das ist doch bestimmt meine aus der
fahrradladen hat leider noch heute auf
und weser musste gestern schon von der
uni nach hause laufen
naja kommt da wenig von seinem
schreibtisch weg es dauert das ganze
noch länger ich glaube er hat eine
affäre mit seiner maßnahme rausschmeißen
gute idee
dann hatte der platz in der bude ganz
gerne zurück zum anfang und vielleicht
seiner schwester nina ricci feiern
na ja sagt jetzt nichts falsch
wenigstens ist dass ich heute abend auch
nicht kann
tschüss flotte an reserven abgesagt
vielleicht sollten wir die feier
verschieben aber ich werde da sein
ich musste kurz weg zur bandprobe dann
komme ich wieder
gleichamberg schon wieder da können wir
die ganze nacht nur für uns okay ich
eine wahl
ich muss ich muss sollen
alles gute zum geburtstag